this is a production of cornell
university
hi this is frank rossi for the cornell
turf grass video log
and we're starting to see right around
the middle of june as the
e.t demand and irrigation systems start
to get challenged
we start to see one of our important
turfgrass pests emerging here in the
northeast
the annual bluegrass weevil and
obviously it's emerged a long time ago
as an adult and now we're starting to
see the damage
face that we're facing from the larvae
eating their way out of the stem
and then chewing on the crowns of the
plant and we typically see this around
the periphery
of fairways where we have a high
percentage of annual bluegrass from
compaction
um and and that those plants start to
get under stress and we start to see the
damage and the smart turf grass managers
are actively
if they are starting to see this damage
they're actively seeding into it
to try to mask the damage obviously
we're still struggling with trying to
find ideal timings and ideal products
for application timing
for this particular pest but the annual
bluegrass weevil remains one
of our important and difficult pests to
manage here in the northeast
and the damage can be severe around the
perimeter of fairways
and surrounds of putting greens thank
you for joining me for the cornell turf
grass video log
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu